[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition
the right stuff yeah yeah i said
the right stuff that's what we're going
to explore today
and i got with me of course my co-host
chuck knight jack
hey neil what's up stand-up comedian and
i got gary o'reilly hey neil nice to
meet you
again okay i have to tell in more than
one of these episodes that we've got a
cool week there's a wiki page on you out
there that i just
stumbled on and you're looking good i
just want to say
all right i must be breathing in
[Laughter]
so uh today's topic the right stuff uh
you
generally heard that applied to
astronauts and in fact
we have a real live authentic astronaut
on this
show because we want to explore what
commonalities there might be
for training to go into space and how
that might impact
the future of training for athletics
just
basically understanding what the human
body is capable of
and who is that astronaut but the one
and only scott kelly scott he's an old
friend scott welcome
welcome to star talk thanks for having
me neil
yeah and some of you if you don't know
who scott kelly is he's one of a twin
and the one twin went into space
this twin and the other twins stayed on
earth and
they the other one went and the other
one went to market
[Laughter]
also known as the u.s senate
[Laughter]
very good very good so you're retired
now retired uh astronaut engineer
naval aviator i got the whole list here
you commanded the international space
station
and you recorded a full year in space
and that was consecutive right not just
in bits and pieces
uh and you you wrote a book a year in
space
a lifetime of discovery i like that
and let me name tag your brother his
name is mark
mark kelly and a current u.s senator
from
arizona john mccain's state
uh arizona so john mccain's old seat
actually that's right and his actual
seat excellent yeah interesting he's
actually sitting at john mccain's
desk you know
is he drinking a beer that he had in the
fridge
um so scott how did you prepare
on earth to go into space
well there's a lot of uh preparation i
think more you're focused on the
physical part of it since this is
you know how does this relate to uh to
sports um
you know we just keep active keep
healthy the astronaut office
has a workout facility with really good
trainers to instruct us
they also teach us how to use all the
exercise equipment which uh
the equipment that we're gonna use in
space which is pretty important because
it's somewhat uh
somewhat complicated and takes some good
technique to use um
but you know mostly for a space flight
what we're
you know our pre-flight preparation with
regard you know physical activity is
more just about staying healthy
and being able to do the job you know
which means being in space for a long
time and the stressors that puts on your
body
and also uh to do space walks which is a
pretty challenging thing to do
so can you compare what we all saw in
the movie the right stuff
with whatever you might have gone
through because the original mercury
seven
it looked like no i i don't want to do
go through that just
you know with the centrifuge and the
survival and this
and and uh so how how
soft are you compared with the original
seven
um i'm not sure you know i'm a little
older than they were when they uh
they started not older than they are now
of course because that was
uh very much before my time but uh you
know regarding the book the
right stuff uh the movie you mentioned
the movie i think i maybe maybe saw it
once really the right the book was
much more significant uh part of my life
really was what's inspired me
to become a better student and uh to go
on and fly in the in the navy and then
later
at nasa so yeah the type of uh stuff you
saw in the movie and
that's related well in the book a lot of
that stuff is the astronaut selection
part you know some of the
uncomfortableness of it
and yeah we have to go through that um
you know
the the uh different uh you know
exams you have to go through from you
know
just a very thorough like uh you know
eye examination to make sure your
vision's good which in some ways is a
little bit uncomfortable believe it or
not all the way you know through your
gastrointestinal system
you know cardiovascularly all that stuff
they test us for uh
claustrophobia uh and how do they do
that they put you in a rubber bag
you know you kind of crawl up into a
ball this like thick rubber
bag uh with a very heavy zipper they put
electrodes on you and push you into a
closet and don't tell you how long
you're going to be there
so okay that's claustrophobia i want to
scream right now
just listening to it just listening to
that i feel like
i feel like calling for help for some
reason right now
and they told you that was a test that
just sounds like
that just sounds like a bunch of bullies
playing a prank on you
yeah yeah that's after they gave you the
wedgies that would actually happen there
well you wouldn't want to have
claustrophobia and get into a spacesuit
and figure it out when you're doing a
spacewalk
yeah i was gonna say you know when
you're in low earth orbit
it might be a little late to figure that
out
hey guys guys like can we uh can
somebody get me down
like i know several astronauts were
were previous athletes like buzz aldrin
i knew he was a track and field athlete
even did the the pole vault i think it
was so did you do any sports when you
were
in college i was a pole vaulter in uh
in high school uh not a very good one i
was the captain of my swim team
i'm a decent swimmer but i shouldn't
have been the captain it's just our team
was so bad
wait wait scott you won the pole vault
contest because you
ended up in space so eventually
you sailed over every night everyone on
the team including my brother who was
also a pole vaulter
and the reason i sailed over him is
because i went on one of those hubble
missions
which is much higher than he ever went
well it's a higher orbit
than the space station that's right
that's right by like
about 100 miles or so i think sibling
rivals
scott i'm interested because going into
space for a year and we know
and i'll hold my hand up astronauts are
elite athletes
you've got amazing cognitive skills high
iq
and strength and conditioning that is as
good as anything you find
on an nfl field or anywhere else for
that matter except for curl
except for curling well they're just
chuck you've gone to the top of mount
olympus there
but we're going to be speaking to dr
mason
a little bit later on in this podcast so
you know stick around for that please
and all our listeners he said to us that
you said when you were in space it felt
like your
bones were melting
and to back that up the blood work and
the urine samples
proved that you were draining calcium
now we're all
told about athletes who can feel and
intuitively know their own body
how did you come to that conclusion
i never said that oh busted
my bones were melting and i doubt
uh very much that uh dr mason said that
either all right
um certainly we lose a lot of bone mass
in space you know one percent a month if
you didn't do anything
to prevent it but we do fortunately
we do a lot of exercise resistive
exercise specifically
helps with that and i did lose some bone
mass
and uh you know that does show up in uh
in your urine samples our body our
bodies are really smart you know we
evolved in gravity and once you get the
space your
physiology recognizes there's no more
gravity no more need for a skeleton to
support it
just getting rid of that stuff so you're
on route to just becoming a pile of
ectoplasm
up there like gumby you like gumby maybe
so this so while all of this is going on
in your body and your body's
is there a point like when people we
speak to who
go to on vegan diets say it takes a
couple of weeks and then they kind of
feel
the whole thing working for them is it
the same situation
for a human body in space where you go
over this bump in the road and after
that you feel comfortable with things
you know there's all different levels of
uh adaptation
you know on a short term flight on us on
a space shuttle uh
the the process really goes exists for
you know it's like a few days where you
might no longer be nauseous
and you kind of feel you still don't
feel great but you
feel good enough to do your job and then
you come home
on a long duration flight i i found the
milestones to be
more like you know one at about a month
in space
and then where you can now kind of you
know
move around very efficiently you can
think pretty clearly
uh you don't feel as
you know your digestive system
and your you know your head isn't as
swollen as it is when you first get up
there because
you know our cardiovascular system again
evolved to push blood against gravity
and without that your head gets swollen
but i would say over the course of me
being there for an entire year
i always felt better in every way
but i never felt like i was on earth
you know i always felt that my head was
a little swollen my
sinuses were a little congested because
of that
um i always had you know like most of
the time a low-grade headache because of
the carbon dioxide but
you know i think maybe there is a maybe
there is a point out there
some kind of inflection point where if
you stay in space long enough
you uh you know you do feel like you're
on earth perhaps
or rather you feel like you're someplace
else and then when you go to earth earth
becomes completely weird
right if you just completely
physiologically adapt
to where you are then earth becomes the
where the outlier
yeah gravity can give you a pretty good
beatdown upon return
yeah so speaking of uh the the change
uh and adaptation so
i read that when you returned
upon inspection when they got under the
hood to see what was going on with your
dna
that seven percent of your dna actually
saw
some change uh now it
i guess subsequently hasn't returned to
its regular state or
what happened with that that seven
percent
and and what exactly was the change that
did we find out exactly what the change
was
well chuck we know that it didn't make
him regrow hair that was a change that
did
not happen which is great
you know why because this is like the
perfect hair for space
i hope to go back someday
but actually you know what changed for
me was uh
my dna but also rna and protein so what
changed was seven percent of my gene
expression okay and gene expression is
whether these things if you think of
them as a switch
they're turned on and off on or off
and that expression controls
you know our physiology how our bodies
react to things how
how they behave this would be a better
question for chris mason but in my case
seven percent of that changed over the
course of the year now granted you know
all of us are probably changing a little
bit all the time
but i think this was more uh more
interesting because it how it uh changed
compared to my brother
with him on earth seven percent of mine
changed uh
relative to him i think more so uh over
the course of that year
and then what is that what is the
implication what are the implications of
that
um for future space travelers and also
myself for my health going forward and
you know hopefully i'll never find out
did they say that your
your chromosomes actually got longer and
to
and here i am so so advanced in my
medical training
that that actually made you younger
so uh what you're referring to is my
telemetry
these like end caps on our chromosomes
and as we age you know cells divide
those get shorter
and uh more frayed so your telomeres are
really an
indication of your physical age and uh
the hypothesis was me being in space all
this radiation the microgravity
environment the stress
the you know all these different factors
would work together
against my chromosomes to shorten them
as compared to my brother
and surprisingly we found out that they
actually
improved now initially we thought well
maybe that's due to the
exercise we do a ton of exercise on
board maybe the diet which is you know
different than a terrestrial diet it's
more controlled by
dietitians maybe that was helpful so
that's what they actually thought at
first
but then i don't know it was six months
or a year after i got back from space we
learned that the japanese had
this experiment on telomeres on the
space station at the same time i was
there
on these small worms and their telomeres
got better
and i never once saw those guys working
out on the treadmill or the bicycle or
anything
so there's clearly more to this than
meets the eye wait scott how many
dangling variables were between you and
mark
so for example did they make mark eat
the same food
you did did he exercise at the same
times
you did so that you have localized the
effect of being in space
as the only difference between the two
of you or was he partying and drinking
and we got we're going with a letter
aren't we
as a scientist neil we i think everyone
realizes
that including yourself clearly that
you know the way you would normally do a
scientific experiment is to control
a lot of these external factors and
variables and focus on you know like the
one thing you're trying to
uh investigate so all things you know
are basically equal right
we actually talked about maybe my
brother following the same diet maybe
following the same
uh exercise protocol but you know he had
his own life
he traveled he had to do work in
different parts of the country really
wasn't
practical so you know it's a it's
express an experiment that
involves some interesting information
it's more of a
you know a longitudinal kind of
experiment you know comparing
me to my brother uh over a long period
of time and other astronauts and not
something where you're looking at a very
specific controlled
very large uh sample group as
you know what you're comparing this uh
me as the
you know scientific uh subject up to
yeah because if you did if you were to
do that perfectly you would lock him
into a vessel the size of your space
station module
for a year as well as well i mean so
that there'd be
the only difference is your zero g above
earth's atmosphere
that would be the plastic bag scenario
that this scop
went through for claustrophobia lock him
in the cupboard
for a year okay the one thing we get
asked all the time and neil
is brilliant with these sort of answers
is what if we did this sport
on this planet right and i'm i think
we're talking to one of the few people
who has come as close
to anybody as doing sport off world even
if it's
exercise or two straws and a bead of
water
so it's what did you think you could
achieve in terms of sport
whilst you're in space for a year
uh you know i think you would have to
design
a sport specifically for microgravity it
would be
hard to translate you know sports that
are conducted
under gravity uh to microgravity and
have them
work the same way certainly you know we
try things
in space for fun i had a football up
there and one time
it took me a few months but i was able
to throw it from the front
of the space station node two all the
way into the service module
of the russian segment which is probably
i don't know like
maybe several hundred feet away and
there was about that much space to
get it through it took me months um
but as far as i don't know maybe you
could have wrestling that would be
pretty interesting neil you're eating
two people wrestling in space i don't
know how you would pin somebody though
yeah dude so i think you're right you
have to sort of start from scratch
and say yeah what are some zero-g
athletic feats that we would because you
know faster
higher stronger whatever is the olympic
motto um
they'd have to even adjust that adjust
it because strength
i don't takes on a different meaning in
space because any force will send
something into motion
and yeah uh so okay so maybe that's
that's a book you i think you should
write yes i'll tell you what though i
think
the the the thing that would be
competitive
would be how you're able to very
precisely maneuver your body around in
zero gravity
because you know over the course the
longer you're there the better you get
at it and
at it and that's really a skill to learn
so
there could be certain things like you
know
um just being able to you know do like
a a flip in in the middle of the module
and see who can do it the longest
without actually hitting anything that
would be
you could time that and that would be a
good competition accidentally hitting
the red eject button
space gymnastics space gymnastics
because everything they do
on the the floor exercises and things
you just do in space
and you don't even have to touch back
down that i like that
and how about synchronized swimming if
they had some swimming pool that was
just a big blob of water
yeah you sort of enter the blob of water
and then you can have cameras
from all directions that'd be
interesting too
probably drowned
all right okay a short competition we've
spoken
a lot about the physical version of you
how about the mental version of you
because
i'm told that you took a gorilla suit
into space
is is that another is that another you
did i'm being told a whole lot
of things oh now my brother sent me a
gorilla suit no i did not take it
i actually said why are you sending me a
gorilla suit and he said
well there's never been a gorilla suit
in space so i'm sending you one
and you have no control over this then
you got to take a blurry photo of you
and then it would be like bigfoot is in
space
you know wouldn't that be cool
i'm these stories are getting lost in
translation
who are you are you talking to the
national enquirer gary
i actually cannot divulge my sources you
know the rules on this chuck so guys we
got we gotta
take this break but uh scott kelly's
book is a year
in space a lifetime of discovery
definitely check it out and when we come
back
we're gonna introduce christopher mason
he's the
medical doctor who conducted the
experiments on scott while he was in
space
for a year and it's his test that gives
us this glimpse
into the effect of human space flight on
human genetics so stay with us
we're back star talk sports edition
building the right stuff we just came
out of a segment with
one of the kelly twins who's been in
space for a year and we found out that a
lot of medical experiments
were conducted trying to find out how
his body compared with
his twin mark who he left here on earth
we've got
right now the doctor who analyzed him
dr christopher mason christ welcome to
star talk
uh it's a pleasure to be here thanks for
having me yeah let me get your your
your title straight here associate
professor and director
the world quant initiative for
quantitative prediction did i get that
right
that's right it's all there yeah yeah
and and you're and you specialize in
physiology and biophysics one of my
favorite fields if i were not an
astrophysicist
i'd be a biophysicist so i'm totally
with you on that
and what is the file family brain and
mind institute
what is that basically looking at
cognitive traits uh in general for when
you large-scale studies including like
with astronauts but then also
looking for genes that are responsible
for how the brain develops or responds
to stress
diseases that run families yeah okay
very interesting and
also the institute for computational
biomedicine
at the wild cornell um at weill cornell
hospital or medicine okay
excellent you're the right guy for this
we have to let people know
that uh you came 15 minutes late to this
interview
because you were like talking to the cdc
and there's no excuse
who who raised you all right
where are your manners here okay just a
few
few mutated viruses floating around the
population a few mutated covert viruses
that's not an excuse
all right um so your
your um the words associated with your
profession
i got one here epi transcriptome
meta genome transcriptone epigenome what
is what is all that
by aqua doodle alpha
that was an old timer joke right there
oh man
just gotta love parliament funkadelic
that's parliament
so chris what is what is all that uh
happy to clarify so it is uh every layer
of biology
being studied sort of in its totality so
you think about you probably
everyone remembers dna and rna and
protein kind of this idea of the central
dogma of
molecular biology what happens in your
cells and how do you go from
you know one cell when you're an embryo
everyone here started as one cell
or at least you should have if you
didn't please tell me later we should do
some experiments on you but
you should have been one cell when you
started and all the instructions are
there to become
all the other cells in your body which
is one of the most beautiful things of
genetics
and but to make that happen you need to
control the dna the rna the protein at
every stage of development
and also when you go to space for
example so the ohms the genome is the
dna the transcriptome is the rna
the proteome is the proteins and all the
ohms in between are the
totality of studying how those molecules
interact in the body
okay but the epi genome is it's
something that happens later
correct it's not what's something that's
sort of you're born with what's going on
there
yeah epi is greek for on top of so you
still have your genome your
your forward letters of genetic code the
a c g's and t's that make
sort of the the recipe of how you make
all your cells you know it's only a
four-letter alphabet that comprises the
entire genetic code for all of life
activities but then on top of that their
epigenome right on top of that
are small chemical tweaks that change
how and when and where something gets
used and so
if you can package dna and like make it
so it's inaccessible and turn things off
or you can
slightly sprinkle kind of like snow
these epigenetic marks that turn them on
and turn them off
so these epigenetic marks they're is it
true or do you know
or has enough been done to study
if indeed trauma over a period of time
leads to a change in genetics
down the line so for instance let's just
say
i'm a survivor of
um you know uh homelessness
right when i'm a little kid and i
go through this terrible trauma uh and
then
i give birth to somebody or better yet
my mom
it goes homeless while she's carrying me
all right so take those two scenarios
one my mom is
homeless suffers that trauma and then
two
i am homeless suffering the trauma so
one i'm fathering a child one i'm giving
birth to a child
will it have indeed an effect an
epigenetic a transgeneration
transgenerational effect so this is a
big question
uh it's hotly debated in the field of
genetics and epigenetics we know
in mice the answer is definitely yes and
in worms the answer is definitely yes we
can see
evidence of multi-generational impacts
where the genetic code is the same
it's what's called an isogenic line it's
like a mouse line that is they're all
the same genetic background there's no
change in the genetics
it's only the epigenetics and you can
you can see it you can see those small
chemical
tweaks in mice where essentially if
you've been lean
you might have a better chance of being
lean as a mouse later in generations
or obese as well you can switch it up
and in nc elegance there's even a case
where
work by odette chavez showed worms that
are have an antiviral response can pass
on for up to three generations
but then it slowly fades away so we know
it's possible biologically but in humans
it's hotly debated
the best example is that in world war ii
a lot of the mothers that were
that were famished because of a lot of
restrictions because they didn't have
enough food
there were a lot of downstream health uh
effects negative because of that and so
there's
there's epidemiological evidence but
it's hard to do the same experiment in
humans
that you do with with mice you can't
force humans to have children with who
you want to uh i mean you can kind of do
with an app
these days but it's it's um you can't do
it in a controlled batch
it's just a it's just the old tender
control group
you can kind of you can get closer but
you still can't yeah so
so one thing you just blew past and i
just want to make sure we like pause and
reflect on that amazing fact
that in the world of experimental you
know physiology
there are catalogs where you can order
up any number of
identical mice oh yeah that someone else
had experimented on
in some other country at another time
that found some effect
so you can get that strain of mice and
it's identical dna to that other mouse
so that now you can look for the soul
variable
are you saying that they they keep that
that line that linear yes
that's why he just blew by it like
everybody
okay so it is knows ideal experimental
um lab animal is it is it
yeah so did i get it right did i get
that right that's spot on and you can
get ones with specific mutations one
that you know age faster like progeria
or ones that have a higher propensity
for diabetes or obesity or cancer
uh you can make almost any kind of mouse
you want these days so now how do you
guys do this you have like a little
mouse brothel that you just
chuck what do you think
[Music]
what it does is makes scott kelly going
to space with his genetically identical
twin brother on earth even more
fantastic
that's why dr mason was the ideal person
to study this stuff
thank you so here we have okay so we
don't have whole colonies of identical
mark kelly's but we had two all right
brought to you by
his their mothers their their mother so
what did what were you looking for
specifically did you know what questions
you wanted to
answer before it all began or you're
just going to
sort of do a scatter a scatter
experiment and see whatever shows up
we had some hypotheses going in but for
the most part we weren't sure and nasa
wasn't sure nobody was sure
what would be the facet of biology that
would change the most is it the dna is
it the rnas the protein
is the microbiome on the microorganisms
in your body uh you know
there's eye and retinal damage that's
been studied before so but we had no
idea so i think the best thing to do
when you don't know where to look
is to look everywhere you possibly can
so in this case
we we put basically took the whole
kitchen sink of molecular biology
and and biophysics and examined
everything we could about everything was
going in their body and out of their
body in
in some parts on their body as well like
the microbiome
and so this uh so we sequenced their
genome the genome of what was in their
stool so we got um some space poop
and also some space skin samples to see
what bacteria were changing and viruses
because there's often herpes it gets
reactivated in a lot of astronauts and
about 40 percent of them
uh herpes gets the immune system's a bit
suppressed and so herpes comes back
reactivated that means they had it
already yeah
yeah and i love it wait a minute are we
talking space herpes here
are we actually talking space i know
it's early in the day but we're already
there
this interview just began dude
but okay but wait a minute just again
you just blew by something i just got to
like pause you for a moment
so you not only concern yourself with
the health and well-being
of scott kelly you also concerned
yourself with the health and well-being
of the bacterial stowaways
that are in his gut and are on his skin
yeah yeah and
then exactly i mean basically because
biology is driven by human cells and
microbial cells
to be a good geneticist you have to look
at all kingdoms of life for every
patient
so now oh man that makes for okay first
of all how do you handle all this data
i mean seriously just just this one
person in space
the tranche of data that comes back to
you has got to be
overwhelming it's got to be huge a tidal
wave
of of just bits and bytes so yeah and
and then you start talking about the
microbial
uh uh aspect of this you're looking at a
whole nother universe
inside of a human being that you're that
you're that you're
quantifying measuring at the same time
how do how do you
how do you even do that well lots of
sequencers so i mean a lot of its
petabytes of data
it is uh i mean we have a bio a
laboratory in most laboratories these
days mine included
it's it's biology it's genetics but
about 65 70
of it is a dry lab so it's all
computational uh just people who just do
programming just do informatics
the other third of it is more the wet
lab and so the lead becomes kind of half
white half dry like a humidor
or like an armpit it depends on what day
it feels like it is but um a little bit
halfway after that so
i did not need to hear that about it
sorry
chris one other thing i just gotta make
sure we're on the same page you just you
just went
right through petabyte so that's the
next metric
group of a thousand that follows
gigabyte so we have
terabytes they're terrible i'm sorry
terabyte gigabyte terabyte and then
petabyte
so thank you so this is way more data
than even you ever be storing on your
computer
right so chris how are you reacting
to data in real time or is it a case of
we'll deal with that when you get back
can i i mean
i mean i'm getting my facts so wrong on
this show it's
actually i'm gonna break records i'm
sure um is there a mini sequencer
on the international space station or
have i dreamt that
as well there is there is so a lot of
when we sequence all the molecules the
dna and the rna and you can even track
these proteins with the sequencers too
uh normally these really big machines
these giant machines
made by like illumina or pacquiao are
some of the bigger companies in this
space and their machines are big
uh but they're smaller ones made by a
company called oxford danapor
out of the uk that makes their just
literally the size of something you'd
say
half the size of your phone or you know
even the size of your phone they are
and you can do sequencing in space we
demonstrated this with kate rubins who's
up in the space station right now and i
was just emailing with her yesterday
uh she has the small she did it for the
first time in 2016 and now it is a
standard flight hardware you can
sequence anything you want right up in
space right oh my god that's so gadoka
dude
that is so scattica it's happening real
time you can so you could kiss someone
quickly swab your
mouth and then sequence it and say do i
want to date this person anymore it's
like 23 and me and tinder coming
together
it's finally happening
right so gattaca was a movie reference
for those who
are uh younger than 40. yeah well
and and by the way if you haven't seen
gattaca get a life
it's a good yeah it's an important film
it's a good it's a great
film and in fact the the letters in the
title of the movie
are your amino acid letters yeah
so so can can i just ask about this
microbial
because i'm just when you think about
the human gut
and the fact that most of us i mean
most of our insides is not us
right right if you think about it most
of our insides is not
us so did you find anything
that might either enhance
our ability for long-term space travel
or detract from our ability
for long-term space travel that's what i
was i was thinking of gary's question
what were you
monitoring in real time like if you knew
scott kelly was like
dying from something do you say oh we're
not going to tell them we need the data
so just take this don't ask why just
just don't ask
we can see because a lot of the
biochemistry of the microbes contributes
to our own
biology and sort of vitamin levels for
example vitamin b3 and b6
a lot of this made by the microbes in
your gut so you can see is the
composition changing in a way that's
negative
but also some of the microbes make
something called arachidonic acid
which has some radio protective
capabilities as well so there's some
ongoing questions of
could you protect astronauts or at least
give them good nutrition but maybe give
them even a little bit of radio
protection
uh both inside and out is ongoing
research at nasa and in our lab yeah
when we say radio protection you mean uh
radiation from space
right yeah um well galactic cosmic rays
will still kind of blow right through
you but if you think about lower
radiation or sort of secondary radiation
it might help you with that yeah just
clarifying that well okay so let me ask
you this neil
how do you deal with like you know the
barrage of radiation that you will
experience
uh once you are you know you're there's
no magnetic field there's no
what do you do the urge to try to find a
biological solution to this i think will
end up
futile relative to what engineers can
design
and so it doesn't take much thickness of
water for example
to completely shield you from most of
what's damaging from the sun
so you can imagine enveloping this the
spacecraft
it's just a a membrane right from some
kind of fluid membrane and that could be
some of the recycled water that you use
so i'm not worried about that everyone's
what about the radiation i'm we got
clever engineers that's the least of my
worries
okay all right so chris what was the
most
interesting set of results you got uh
maybe the most disturbing but the same
breath
but um and the lessons we've actually
picked up from
scott's year in space i think where are
you hiding the andromeda stream
it's in the freezer it's i mean oh wait
no i mean it's uh another movie
now you're gonna be over 50
so i think it's really surprising to see
actually how plastic the body was
many many things changed that were
stress responses in flight but
and even when he landed he really his
whole body broke out into a rash when
his ankles swelled up to the size of
basketballs but it went back to normal
so a lot of the body did return to
normal
but he did we did see increased damage
to his dna so we know he did get
radiated so it's something to keep an
eye on
telomeres got a little bit longer we
could see which was surprising
and one other thing that's really
surprising is we could see his immune
system you could see which bacteria it
was actually engaging with
because we've also sequenced the walls
of the space station so we can see
the bacteria that he's his body's inner
engaging with and the immune cells you
can actually see
uh the t cells in his body becoming more
active towards those specific microbes
that was kind of a really interesting
result
okay so it means you could not up front
disentangle the effects of zero g versus
a slightly lower pressurized environment
versus the rated exposure that he's
getting
all of those are happening together
because when i think of microbes do they
really care how much gravity there is
like they live in a whole other world
where sort of the
you know uh other forces dominate what
role gravity would play
so it sounds like most of what you're
finding has nothing to do with zero g
yeah we think it's a lot of it's the the
stress on the body sometimes you get
local
hypoxia just because there's small
clouds of co2 because air doesn't move
the same way in space as it does
here on earth essentially the clouds can
stay a little bit in front of your face
you can see some of that in the blood
work even
so we think you see that you see that
you know essentially the radiation the
stress of the flight yeah
so you know carry a fan with you
wherever you go yeah there's a lot of
fans on the space station to make sure
the air moves
yeah so scott's in space for a year
that's not the record is it no the
russians have his beat like with many
things
okay that's that's why it's called a
spike that's because they punish
somebody to put him up there
you know what happened was yeah they
were like russia's beat russia's just
beat
us in everything in space first first
satellite first non-human animal first
human first woman first black person
right they had everything and then we
landed on the moon we say
we win so having said that
we will need to do experiments as you
did with scott
for even longer periods of time with
possibly even more sophistication it's
where are we not in terms of the length
of time possibly because what is it nine
months to get to mars the projection
yeah seven months here yeah i mean i
mean what sort of tests can you conduct
what sort of time can a human exist
in space at this particular point in our
technological evolution
there are missions planned now for doing
18 months and there's going to be a
barrage of 6 and 12 month additional
missions to follow up on the twin study
so by the time we send people to mars
you know if you ask nasa it's 20 35 if
you ask elon musk it's you know 20 26 or
something so
uh but it's never so don't ask me yeah
okay
you know you don't think we're going to
go you think never that's a whole other
thing
don't don't get me started actually you
wrote a whole book on thinking about
humans and the future the next 500 years
why don't we take a break and we'll come
back
and just explore where that book goes
and why
and what you found and what your
insights are as a medical professional
we'll be right back on star talk
we're back star talk sports edition we
let off with
scott kelly one of the twins who went
into space and got studied by
our current guest we've got dr mason
here who's
who's an expert on the human genome and
the human physiology and biophysics
and he's the right guy in the right
place doing the right thing so again
thanks
uh for being on our show so let me ask
you
did uh what is there anything we learned
that we can apply to the rest of us even
if we're not going into space
from what you studied with uh mark
kelly's physiology
yeah yeah i think because we you know we
studied and let me be specific anything
we can know about pandemics or any you
know
i got to sort of throw that in the mix
viruses yeah they're
physiology or in response to stress for
example so what's amazing is
we about a year ago you know we started
getting a lot of samples from
the hospital new york presbyterian the
covet 19 patients coming in we started
sequencing them
applying some of the exact same
molecular technologies that we did to
the kelly twins and other astronauts
and we could actually see for example
some things that look just like uh
like that look like the stress of
landing back from space like
interleukin-6 is a
a basically a cytokine an inflammatory
signaling molecule
that really spiked up when he landed so
when he landed back on earth it looked
like his body
basically was saying oh crap you know
i'm not breaking on rashes i'm in a lot
of pain
and it was because you could see these
cytokines these pro and
anti-inflammatory
signals and molecules battling each
other wait this is not because he had
landing anxiety it's because the body
was beginning to feel gravity once again
exactly exactly and so getting back to
1g the body
releases all these signals that are kind
of an alarm bell to say okay we need to
begin to use our muscles
rebuild our bones even though they work
out on the space station and try to
prevent as much of that as possible
it still is different when you come back
to a full 1g on your whole body
the whole time it hurts a little bit and
we could see some of those same
signatures show up in covid patients so
what's interesting is
we published a paper last year saying
what's the list of possible medications
that you could use
when you land on gravity after you
haven't been in gravity a lot of them
overlap with what are now being used for
therapies for coven 19 which you know we
couldn't have predicted
a year ago but and now we can see it and
then even the sequencer we use a little
tiny sequencer we've
used in space that gives you sequence
data you know within minutes we now
sequence uh coronaviruses on that same
machine
wow okay you know this is this sounds
like some badass stuff
and we introduced you as associate
professor why aren't you full professor
oh i oh the thanks for the lead i just
got promoted uh
okay so it's just just now full
professor if
while cornell didn't promote you we
would okay
but you are now knighted full professor
keep this going dude
so those who are unfamiliar with
academia full professor is really simply
you have a higher salary but everything
all the other expectations are the same
of you to
keep stay badass in this because you've
already had tenure
so that wasn't the threshold here so
when you're looking at scott
and you're looking at his physiology uh
is there something that we can take away
from that
for like uh our daily
exercise routines and things like that
like i read somewhere that
running for instance helps increase bone
density like the pounding
actually does something to tell your
brain to
strengthen your bones is there anything
that we can take like that from
your studies from these we've seen when
they run in space there's actually
you know they have to wear bungee cords
to keep themselves down but
that that that hammering on your knees
and it tells your bones
to really uh you know maintain this this
homeostasis
and there's also something called
hormesis which means when you kind of
push yourself a little bit
if you ever lift weights a little bit
you push yourself hard you're kind of
sore that next day
but it's a good sore and so we've seen
some of that you need to actually push
yourself a little bit
a little bit more if you can not every
time you work out and break a record
every time but it helps to do so
and now and again and it's because it
helps stimulate the body that way so you
know pushing yourself a little bit is
one simple thing they do actually with
some of the
exercise regimens in space and also and
they're
monitoring the body you can actually see
we could you know scott i don't you know
when he talked about in his book that if
he didn't work out every day
he could almost feel like his bones were
dissolving
which is awful to think about but then
as amazing as in the urine data
we could see the calcium coming out of
his body so he wasn't imagining it was
actually happening and if you don't have
that
you know consistent activation of your
body's rebuilding
you know you'll atrophy your bones will
slowly go away now chris i have to just
correct something you said
you said that the bungee cords keep them
down but in
space there is no doubt i just i
okay so it keeps you pulled towards the
running machine
wherever that running machine is okay so
scott's got a book out
yeah a year in space a lifetime of
discovery but your book professor
the next five hundred years because if
we could gary say that with some drama
please
the next 500 years give me some emotion
in that my gosh
uh a spectacular read coming to you
very shortly is the next 500 years
all right by professor mason all right
what are you going to ask them all right
so if we go back 500 years
the the discoverer ferdinand magellan
discovers guam
now that's ancient that's like sailing
ships and weird
in 100 years 500 years time are we going
to be looking back at your work now
which is so exciting and think
that's ancient that's boring
that's my second great homework that's
right exactly
so i mean how are people going to view
this and where is
500 years what can we do how can we
there's a lot there's a million
questions to
why do you think you know what have
happened in 500 years yeah
i i have it's a it's a treatise of hope
i guess if you will i put it together as
uh what i think humanity can do and also
should do and that we have a duty to do
so when you think of duty
most people immediately get sleepy you
think of a duty to what to like feed my
cats
a duty to maybe your spouse maybe to
your country
uh maybe it's patriotic but you'll
hopefully have a duty to your
kids but even that is not guaranteed
right some people just completely forego
that duty
but there is one duty that we have as
humans that as soon as you understand it
is actually something you can
control and that you can have influence
on the universe is just being aware of
extinction we're the only species that
we know of that is aware of extinction
so then we have a duty to prevent it not
only our own but also any other species
and life form that we come across so
we have kind of a duty to the universe
that is actualized at the moment you
realize that you understand what
extinction is wait do you have a duty to
a species that would go extinct without
us
because the tree of life is
there's no end of extinction on it and
it has nothing to do with us
and the fact that the dinosaurs went
extinct pried open an ecological niche
that allowed us to rise up so who are
you to pass judgment
on what life form should or should not
go extinct if we have nothing to do
with that extinction i it's even
independent of whether we cause it or
not is that life so it i start from the
premise that that life and actually
self-aware life that his life as aware
of extinction
is unique in the universe and and any
other life that doesn't have it doesn't
have this duty so
even extinct life even if we didn't
cause it you can bring it back but you
have to do it carefully because what if
you bring it back if you bring back
dinosaurs they probably would
rampage you don't eat a lot of but you
know you're not necessarily advised
so you know i think we should start on
an island a small island but what could
go wrong right you know jurassic park
yeah right right so what could go wrong
no but it but it conceptually is
there there are species we clearly cause
their extinction and i think we have a
moral duty to try and even bring them
back especially those with genetic
technologies we can do so
some of those same technologies and
allow us to make immunotherapies where
you can engineer your t cells to go
after cancer cells very exquisitely
now so this idea of genome engineering
and cellular engineering is already
deployed in clinical trials around the
world
and some of that same technology lets us
be sort of the safe
guardians and shepherds of life and
maybe even bring it back but that is uh
we're in no hurry to do that that would
be very
slow i'd like that's a very i'd like
that so you're not some sci-fi guy
thinking what new contraption we're
going to have or what new spaceship
you're thinking of our duty to ourselves
to our civilization and to the planet
and our ecosystem i think that's a noble
cause so in 500 years if all goes as you
want what what
what does it all look like so hopefully
we would end up to mars eventually which
is the first step on a stairwell towards
preservation because
like every moral question becomes
immediately clear when you put it out to
a billion years that's when the sun gets
big enough to start to
heat the earth and it's really going to
be really hard to live here if you go
out five billion years the sun's
probably going to be at the surface of
the
of the earth like they're going to be
touching and kissing so no matter what
we do if we achieve perfect pieces of
species
and perfect technological bliss if we're
still physically here uh
you know really even in a billion years
then that's it for us and so i think
we're worth preserving
and that means eventually we have to
start going so we have to start to go to
the moon to mars
i think by 400 years from now we might
be able to get to have some people in
titan
and at the end of the book at 500 years
i say we might have enough knowledge and
understanding of physiology to be able
to send people on what's called a
generation ship
where people live and die from multiple
generations on their way towards a new
star
so are you incl you're including in this
genetic modifications to us
in the service of this longevity and
this uh
insight because i think we might need to
the other option if you send humans to a
planet that they've not evolved on is
like just say good luck and hopefully
you survive but if you have
uh biochemical and genetic capacity to
protect people and we don't use it that
would be actually more unethical so we
could actually protect you from
assuming it works and it's safe of
course which we have to prove so ethics
is a big part of this book so what about
the ethics
of sending a group of fertile people
into space
who then give birth to a next generation
a generational ship and that generation
is born only ever knowing
that their job is to have another
generation so that
some generation down the line gets to
land at get
gets the prize and so isn't that a form
of
prison or slavery yeah you know what i'm
going to call that a form of early
civilization here on earth because
honestly that's all earth early or
civilization whatever it was
that's all it ever was it's here we are
on this rock spirit and i'm gonna have
some babies in this new place
and the whole thing is have some babies
we're stuck here we gotta have more
babies so that we can stay here
and now here we are where we are there's
no eight eight billion of us
but human evolution has been migration
whether it's been
north south east west mainly east west
because of temperate zones and all the
rest of it
so the once we've kind of got to a point
on this planet
the migration to another seems to be
just another development of our humans
being human
yeah and i mean at the moment we've got
russia and china
joining forces to go and build some sort
of bases on the moon or around the moon
i mean i'll be looking at this chris as
because of
think of this problem scott experienced
coming back after a year in space
physically
would we use things like moon bases call
them that as stepping stones back into
one g
rather than just come straight back to
earth absolutely it'd probably be easier
i mean that's one sixth gravity there
and you know mars is you know
38 gravity so hopefully these will give
you a little stepping stone so it
wouldn't be as bad
but then you know eventually you know
think about people who just live
you know think about what happened the
australians when they left england they
got a different accent they gave a
different culture you get
you know on different planet you get
different physiology as well so we would
expect them to become different
plus the deer in australia have pouches
you know i think well the great thing
about the uh i guess at the end is that
we've discovered all the new genes that
we didn't know existed even 20 years ago
and we've discovered all these planets
exoplanets that we didn't even know 25
years ago so
i call them twin engines and discovery
because now we know what genes we can
use to understand them and keep us safe
potentially we know which planets we
could eventually go to so i hope 500
years from now
we would pick the best one or several
and then send people there and maybe
we'd get some
interesting you know sitcoms that get
broadcast from this other new planet
potentially
i think it's it's brilliant to have this
addition to
the futurist's portfolio because it's
usually some technologist
it's um fantasy writer it's it's
somebody imagining a future
and you're coming at it physiologically
i think that's that's a brilliant
construct for a book and
uh we'll look for it on the bestseller
list if it's not already
there yeah because that's totally what
we should all be thinking about
rather than just the next two years or
the next four years for an election
is anyone thinking about the next
century yeah
so let me ask you this how do you feel
this is not related to anything that
we're talking about i'm just interested
in your opinion
on the project to take
500 fertilized
eggs and put them on the moon
at the same way we did with seeds and
wherever we put the seeds what was what
you mean to store them on the moon to
store them on a moon
basically like a seed vault but for
humankind
um it would be they'd have to be really
well maintained up there
you know tardigrades fell on the moon
when the israeli spacecraft crashed on
there a year and a half ago so
and i think those have all been probably
irradiated and not useful but i think
if they were buried deep and they
radiated and now they're large
right there you see the right movies
chris
when you get radiated you become big
okay
and green sometimes thank you yeah yeah
so there uh so i mean i think it's uh i
think preserving
you know we can actually embed a lot of
the genomes now in a digital code right
so this is being done something called
the genome arc project
sequencing as many genomes on the earth
as possible as kind of a reservoir
of human and biological diversity of
everything we know on earth and so i
think
you can put it in digital form that
might be simpler interesting good point
because
chuck i can write a book on engines
and store the book i don't have to store
the engine right okay you can read the
book the information about the engine
and then rebuild the engine
so that's uh so we gotta we gotta land
this plane at some point
wow i don't so chris let me let me take
us out with this final question to you
yeah um what have you
genetically engineered in your basement
we won't tell anyone oh
just what do you have just you can
whisper it
okay we won't tell anybody just a couple
of things
a couple we've got a butterfly that
tastes like barbecue sauce
we do have one thing in the lab that's
true though we took genes from
tardigrades that can resist radiation
and put them into human cells and now
they have eighty percent more resistant
to radiation so
uh that is something we have done with
tardigrades and now you can actually you
know take some of these
immune function genes and also put them
in cells so where it means you can go
repair
chernobyl yeah potentially i mean i
think any gene we see from any species
on this planet or others can be
essentially part of the genetic toolbox
of surviving
right because nature already gave it to
you you're just rearranging them right
right very cool but safely and carefully
and in one space and not
releasing to the world yes yes well
chris good luck with the book
it's a fascinating topic and i think is
an underserved
topic and you're the clearly the right
person to put that out there
so uh thanks for being on star talk we
would totally want to have you
back on again because if for no other
reason we'll find some reason
to bring you back on because you do
fascinating work congratulations on your
promotion
to professor um and so that means you're
old and gray i think is yeah
and it's a pipe you have to smoke
[Laughter]
all right chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure uh tweeting at
chuck nice comic gary tweeting at my
three left feet is that it correct yes
yeah chris are you do you have social
media presence yeah just mason
underscore lab mason lab yep
mason lab all right on twitter i guess
that is yes yes sir yeah all right well
we'll keep an eye on you
all right everyone this has been star
talk sports edition the right stuff
and as always i'm neil degrasse tyson
bidding you
to keep
[Music]